Few experiences in childhood have a more
enduring impact than the relationships
we have with our siblings. Research
shows that having a good relationship
with our brothers or sisters can
reduce feelings of loneliness,
depression, and anxiety. But a new
survey finds parental favoritism—the
perception that there was a favorite child
in the family—may negatively influence
sibling relationships. Think sibling rivalry.
Forty percent of Americans with siblings say
their parents had a favorite. Why does this
matter? Lots of reasons, but here’s three:
First, it increases feelings of social
Isolation. Americans who report that their
parents had a favorite child report
feeling lonely more often growing up
Second, it damages sibling relationships. This
group also reports that they were not
as close to their siblings growing up.
Third, it undercuts trust in parents.
They are less likely to turn to their
parents when they had a problem growing up.
Finally, research has also shown that parental
favoritism is universally problematic, and
not just for those who aren’t the favorite.
Growing up, do you think your parents had
a favorite child? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you’d
like our scholars to talk about in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.